j'ouvre notre second débat consacré à
l'influence du de la France en Afrique
alors qu'une épidémie employons ce terme
de coup d'état frappe les pays
francophones depuis 2 ans coup sur coup
le Niger puis le Gabon ce sont rajoutés
à la liste pendant l'été quels
conséquences pour les intérêts français
quelle place la Russie et la Chine
sont-elles en train de prendre sur le
continent africain avant d'en débattre
Fabien requaire nous raconte ses
journées de manifestations encore
aujourd'hui contre les militaires la
présence des militaires français au
Niger
des milliers de manifestants rassemblés
dimanche devant une base militaire de la
France à Niamey pour exiger le départ
des 1500 soldats français stationnés au
Niger
depuis le coup d'État du 26 juillet la
jante au pouvoir dénonce les accords de
coopération militaire qui lie la France
et son ancien allié dans le cadre de la
lutte anti-terroriste la France de son
côté ne reconnaît pas l'autorité des
puccistes dirigée par le général tiani
dans un entretien au journal Le Monde la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
justifiées dimanche le maintien de
l'ambassadeur de France à Niamey qui
s'est pourtant vu retirer son visa
diplomatique par la jante nous n'avons
pas à nous ranger aux injonctions d'un
ministre qui n'a aucune légitimité ni
pour les pays de la sous-région ni pour
l'Union africaine ni pour les Nations
Unies ni pour la France Guinée Mali
Burkina Niger depuis 2021 les coups
d'État se succèdent sur le continent et
en particulier dans la zone d'influence
française dernier push en date le 30
août au Gabon des militaires chez astali
Bongo du pouvoir la France condamne mais
s'abrite derrière une fausse légitimité
selon ce spécialiste un coup d'État
militaire qui interrompt un coup d’état
électoral on allait avoir un énième coup
d'état électoral puisque le Gabon est
coutumier du fait et ça allait être le
troisième coup d’état électoral pour
alibongo lui-même donc 2009 2016 et la
2023 et finalement on a un coup d'État
militaire qui vient interrompre ce
processus en protégeant ses alliés
d'hier au nom de la préservation de ses
intérêts la France est attirée les
foudres de la population en Afrique
reste à savoir si ces bouleversements
sur le seul Africain qui marque un recul
de l'influence française au bénéfice
d'autres acteurs tels que la Russie ou
la Chine annonce tout non la fin de la
France Afrique
la France est-elle condamnée à voir son
influence déclinée en Afrique c'est le
thème de notre débat avec niagali
Bagayoko bonjour bonjour bienvenue à
vous vous êtes chercheuse spécialiste
des questions de sécurité en Afrique et
présidente de l'africaine security
secteur network Gérard longheim bonsoir
et bienvenue à vous vous êtes sénateurs
de la Meuse ancien ministre de la
Défense j'accueille également saïdique
Abba bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste écrivain nigérien président
du Centre international de réflexion et
d'études sur le Sahel et puis je cite
votre livre Mali Sahel notre Afghanistan
à nous avec un point d'interrogation
publié aux éditions impacts Mathieu
croissanto éditoris politique est resté
à mes côtés évidemment je commence avec
le Niger Niaga les Bagayoko on a vu les
les images de manifestations la presse
de la base militaire de soldats français
à Niamey est-ce qu'ils sont en danger
tout simplement est-ce qu'on peut
mesurer l'état de de d'exaspération ou
de violence potentielles qui entourent
ces manifestations moi je ne pense pas
que les soldats
soit en danger physiquement parce qu'ils
ont tout simplement les moyens de se
défendre en revanche le degré
d'hostilité de colère de la population
est réelle et je pense qu'il est très
important de ne pas y voir des
manipulations c'est un sentiment qu'on a
vu croître moi personnellement au fil
des années il y a un très fort rejet de
la présence militaire internationale au
Niger et il ne faut pas oublier que
c'est dans ce pays que ces produits l'un
des plus graves incidents ayant impliqué
un convoi de l'opération barkhane qui
avait été pris à partie par des
manifestants en colère et cet incidence
était soldé par trois morts quand vous
dites ne pas forcément y voir les
manipulations vous pensez quoi
l'influence russe dont on parle beaucoup
la ministre Wagner c'est à ça que vous
pensez manipulation
à la jante elle-même au CNSP il ne faut
pas oublier que l'organisation qui a
appelé à cette manifestation hier qui
s'appelle le m62 c'est constitué il y a
exactement un an en août l'année
dernière sur la base du rejet de la
présence militaire française c'est son
ADN donc ça précède le coup d'État et ça
précède bien entendu toute présence
internationale plus largement pour ce
qui est de la question de Wagner ou de
la Russie je pense qu'il est très
important de cesser de considérer que
les Africains sont manipulés ou qu'ils
sont des magnets aux mains de
l'extérieur quel qu'il soit juste pour
terminer c'est le même discours que ce
pour moi qui accuse en permanence la
France d'être derrière tous les complots
je pense qu'il y a une très forte
volonté aujourd'hui en Afrique de
prendre son destin en main et qu'il faut
prendre ça en considération au-delà des
intérêts des partenaires internationaux
le l'ambassadeur français au Niger il
est il est toujours mettre en place à
malgré la volonté du nouveau pouvoir de
de l'expulser la France veut pas céder
est-ce qu'elle a raison oui
vous dites le nouveau pouvoir c'est un
pouvoir de fête qui n'a pas de
légitimité c'est en tous les cas le
point de vue de la CDAO auquel
appartient le Niger et qui ne reconnaît
pas les hommes du coup d'État et donc et
par ailleurs quand bien même mirait-il
les hommes du coup d'État exerçant un
pouvoir de fait il y a des conventions
internationales que leur pays a signé et
qui protège le personnel diplomatique
donc le que le notre ambassadeur puisse
ne puisse rien faire c'est certain qu'il
soit obligé de partir la réponse est non
mais ce qu'on sera pas c'est du cabas
finalement la France obligé de discuter
un jour ou l'autre avec cette jante avec
ce nouveau pouvoir en tout cas il y a
aujourd'hui une posture de confrontation
qui est celle de la France parce que
l'ambassadeur de France veut retirer son
agrément et la jointe a pris par la
ensuite deux arrêtés et a fait rendre
une décision une ordonnance du tribunal
reclasse de Niamey pour justement
conférer un caractère légal et rendre
irrévocable la décision d'expulsion bon
la France a choisi
la posture de refuser jusqu'ici
l'arrêté d'expulsion tel qu'il a été
pris et on s'installe aujourd'hui dans
une situation de confrontation puisque
monsieur it ne peut pas sortir du
périmètre de son ambassade et pour ceux
qui connaissent bien la configuration de
l'ambassade à Niamey la résidence et
l'ambassade sont séparés donc s'il a la
résidence c'est qu'il ne peut plus aller
à l'ambassade s'il est à l'ambassade ce
qui ne peut plus aller à la Résidence
puisque il y a une voie qui traverse les
deux et à partir du moment où ils sont
de l'ambassade la protection n'est plus
assurée donc on est dans une situation
Kaf Cayenne et à mon avis peut-être que
la posture la plus courante aurait été
celle d'acte malgré le caractère
légitime la décision de la gente je
rappelle simplement que lorsque nous
sommes quand même dans un même cas de
figure au Burkina Faso au Mali et
lorsque la jointe les jantes ont demandé
le départ de l'ambassadeur de France
particulièrement pour le Burkina sont
rappelles il a été rappelé lorsque le
Mali l'a expulsé il est parti à mon avis
nous sommes dans une posture de
confrontation porteuse de risque je
voudrais rebondir sur ce qu'il y a
d'aller a dit et il n'y a pas de risque
physique mais je parlais avec Monsieur
Longuet qui a été mise à la défense les
militaires ne sont pas préparés au
maintien de foule on a vu un déferlement
de foule et si jamais ces deux forment
de poule si jamais les barrières CD on
se retrouverait dans une confrontation à
l'ivoirienne vous savez il y a ce
souvenir où les militaires français ont
été confrontés à une foule en colère en
Côte d'Ivoire et ont dit tirer et il y a
eu beaucoup de victimes on avait évoqué
au palais de la CEDEAO qui représente
les pays de l'Afrique de l'Ouest on
avait évoqué une intervention militaire
pilot par la CD est-ce que au Niger
est-ce que c'est toujours d'actualité
est-ce que ça a été est-ce que c'est une
piste est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres alors
c'est toujours officiellement
d'actualité cette option militaire a été
brandie pour appuyer les négociations en
réalité et il semble que c'est cette
voix qui soit désormais privilégiée par
la plupart des acteurs mais on a vu une
mobilisation des contingents sénégalais
notamment des contingents du Bénin ce
qui s'est produit c'est qu'il y a une
très forte mobilisation internationale
pour favoriser la voie diplomatique le
chef de fil de cette initiative est
plutôt l'Algérie qui est très soutenu
dans ce sens à la fois par les
États-Unis par la Russie par l'Allemagne
par l'Italie par les Pays-Bas par
l'Union africaine dans une certaine
mesure donc cette option militaire qui
était surtout portés par le Nigéria au
départ semble un peu perdre de sa
crédibilité à l'heure qu'il est alors
dans l'actualité de ce président de la
République
qui les prisonnier certes mais il était
élu et c'est le seul président de la
République élu au Niger en ce moment à
cet instant et je crois que le président
Macron a eu raison d'être très carré
très clair comme Madame Colonna ne
faitions nous demande la vie du
gouvernement français et je ne suis pas
dans la majorité présidentielle je
trouve que le président a raison d'être
clair il faut s'habituer à soutenir les
présidents élus alors il y a la question
elle se pose aussi au Gabon puisque dans
l'actualité de ce lundi il y avait ces
manifestations devant la base militaire
française à Agnès au Niger mais il y
avait aussi ce serment prêté par celui
qui se fait nommer président de la
Transition Brice olivingéma qui voilà
en vêtu de d'un habit militaire enfin
vous allez voir l'image est-ce que ça
sonne comme un président de transition
je ne sais pas mais mais on va tout de
suite entendre voilà je l'attendais
voilà l'image c'est son avis
protocolaire pour être précis voilà ce
que nous dit le nouveau président
de la transition
à l'issue de cette transition
avec l'apport de tous les Gabonais
partenaire au développement
nous entendons remettre le pouvoir aussi
vite
en organisant des nouvelles élections
libres transparente et crédible dans la
paix sociale
[Applaudissements]
alors il y a des Bagayoko il faut
peut-être expliquer c'est Ali Bongo qui
a été on va dire destitué par ce nouveau
pouvoir sauf que le nouveau président
quoi est un projet quand même dans la
dans la galaxie Bongo c'est ça qui qui
tient le pouvoir dans ce pays depuis
plusieurs décennies c'est la famille
la victoire d'Ali Bongo mais
manifestement de manière fausse mais un
certain nombre d'éléments laissent
entendre qu'il y a une lutte de clan à
l'intérieur de ce système et la question
de savoir qui va triomphé à l'intérieur
de celui-ci et il n'est pas évident que
cela se fasse au bénéfice de la
démocratie le Président de la Transition
cesdikaba est-ce qu'on peut croire à ce
à cette terminologie
le coup d'État n'était pas la seule
possibilité puisque un scrutin venait de
se tenir au Gabon il était possible
aussi de voir de recompter le voit voir
si l'opposition effectivement gagner qui
a gagné et se passer de cette situation
de coup d'état parce que lorsqu'on acte
aujourd'hui comme le fait la France le
reste de la communauté internationale un
coup ça veut dire on rentre dans une
catégorisation de coup d'état des bons
coups d'État et des mauvais coup d'État
que ce coup d'État est bon
courage une certaine donc là vous avez
vu peu de temps après le coup d'État
l'ambassadeur de France a rencontré et
d'après ceux qui en ressort euh il a
donné le nouveau président le transition
comme on l'appelle maintenant à donner
des gages à la France sur le maintien de
ses intérêts sur donc est-ce que cela
est suffisant pour actuel le coup d'État
et considérer que c'est un bon coup
d'État parce que si on fait cela ça
risque de d'être contre-productif il y a
une volonté aujourd'hui d'arrêter
l'hémorragie de coup d'état puisque elle
se succède nous en sommes au 8e
peut-être coup d'État si on inclut le
chat qui est un coup de un demi coup
d'état ou un coup d'État comme on veut
donc si on on choisit cette posture aura
un on dit je pense que les militaires un
peu partout vont considérer que il y
aura une période où la communauté
internationale va critiquer après elle
va s'accommoder donc ça risque d'être
contre-productif de considérer
aujourd'hui que bon la transition s'est
installée et que il faut passer à autre
chose même si on sait que le président
du Bongo comme il avait fait en 2016
était dans la situation d'inverser le
résultat et de se déclarer vainqueur de
ce scooter alors on voit derrière vous
s'afficher cette cette carte
effectivement on pourrait presque parler
d'une épidémie de putsch ou de coup
d'état depuis un peu plus de 2 ans
depuis le chat en avril
2021 le Tchad puis le Mali au mois de
mai il y avait déjà eu à côté un an plus
tôt la Guinée en septembre 21 le Soudan
un mois plus tard le Burkina Faso en
septembre 2022 et puis donc cet été coup
sur coup en juillet et août le Niger et
le Gabon je vous propose d'entendre je
suis sûr qu'en régie tout le monde va me
suivre ce spécialiste de l'Afrique qui
réagit à cette à cette épidémie à cet
effet domino je sais pas s'il faut
employer cette terminologie il s'appelle
Thomas Borel il est spécialiste de
l'Afrique il vient de publier une
histoire de la France Afrique lui il dit
qu'on peut parler de contagion écoute en
le
se passer c'est dans plusieurs pays
simultanément parfois même trois pays
voisins comme c'est le cas au Mali au
Burkina Faso au Niger où on a un recul
important et comme si ça se produit un
peu partout en même temps là ça devient
une très mauvaise nouvelle pour les
autorités françaises parce
qu'effectivement et cette idée de
contagion dites les autorités en tout
cas de d'exemples de modèles ça donne
des idées à d'autres bien évidemment de
la même manière que en 2011 quand la rue
a renversé des dictatures en Tunisie et
en Egypte ça a donné des idées dans les
pays voisins donc ils pourraient se
passer la même chose mais ça il faut
attendre le vent en tout cas c'est une
période assez excitante
est-ce que vous parlez vos sites
contagieux est-ce qu'on peut faire
autrement que en voyance voilà cette
liste des astrueuse et surtout quelles
sont les risques liés à cette contagion
pour vous
alors moi je ne sais pas s'il faut
véritablement parler de contagion
qui laisse penser qu'on efface à une
vague de type révolutionnaire
autoritaire et conservatrice qui
bénéficie d'un soutien populaire c'est
ça qui est extrêmement préoccupant parce
que ces coups d'État à l'exception très
nos stables des coups d'État qui sont
survenus au Tchad que je qualifiais en
effet de coup d'état et du Soudan ont
bénéficié d'un soutien massif dans la
rue alors même que ce sont très souvent
les principes de démocratie de droits de
l'homme qui sont remises en cause et on
en vient à ce que disait c'est dit que
tout à l'heure un principe c'est un
principe et il n'est pas négociable il
n'y a pas de bon ou de mauvais coup
d'État quand l'Union africaine quand la
CDEAO ou la CEAC pour ce qui concerne le
chat dans le la différence ou le Gabon
la France ou tout autre partenaire
international considèrent qu'il n'y a
pas à sanctionner le chat c'est ce qui
s'est passé c'était la première fois que
l'Union africaine ne sanctionnait pas ce
pays alors que
l'accession au pouvoir d'une jungle qui
plus est avec à sa tête le fils du
président décédé accéder au pouvoir en
violation de tous les textes rien ne
s'est produit et je pense que le
tournant s'est produit à ce moment-là
donc oui il y a à s'inquiéter de ce
phénomène parce qu'en effet tous les
acteurs internationaux sont
décrédibilisés en raison des doubles
standards qu'ils ont appliqué en
fonction des situations et je pense oui
qu'on est face à un nouveau mouvement il
y avait eu dans les années 90 des
révolutions favorables à la démocratie
qui avait été très puissante aujourd'hui
je pense qu'on est dans une vague très
réactionnaire à l'inverse votre avis
là-dessus
les principes démocratiques qui sont en
danger aujourd'hui en gros je partage ce
cette analyse c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle je soutiens avec
conviction le président qui n'a pas
démissionné et qui a été élu
démocratiquement et assez largement
reconnu au Niger maintenant le vrai
problème pour la France est-elle en
mesure de faire quelque chose d'utile
pour des pays dont l'explosion
démographique constitue un défi
invraisemblable que nous ne sommes pas
certains nous Européens de pouvoir
contribuer à à régler
utilement bénéfice des populations et je
crois que on parle de la France Afrique
ça n'a rien à voir avec la réalité
d'aujourd'hui France-Afrique c'était en
1960 j'ai regardé les chiffres le Niger
c'est moins de 6 millions d'habitants
ils sont à 22 c'est à dire pratiquement
trois fois plus comment pouvons-nous
avec les moyens français qui sont
limités je parle les moyens humains pas
les moyens financiers l'argent peut
toujours en donner c'est pas ça qui
assure le succès d'une coopération c'est
l'engagement des personnes et des
entreprises or il n'y a pas cette
volonté aujourd'hui en France parce
qu'il n'y a pas les capacités humaines
pour le faire et l'Afrique celle que je
connais l'Afrique francophone a besoin
de soutien et donc moi ce qui me
terrifie aujourd'hui c'est que nous
avons des jeunes qui manifestent qui la
France devient le bouc émissaire bon
d'accord on fait le Doron on attend que
ça passe mais le fond du problème mais
ça c'est ce qu'on faisait à chaque fois
peut-être est-ce que c'est pas différent
cette fois-ci c'est pas du tout là on a
aujourd'hui un problème qui a un
problème de société avec une explosion
démographique avec une pauvreté dont on
n'arrive pas à se débarrasser et pas de
perspective de de de réussite d'ailleurs
le Gabon est quand même aussi une
tragédie 40% de la population et sous le
seuil de pauvreté alors que c'est un des
pays d'Afrique les plus riches par ces
ressources de minières et pétrolières
nous avons
il y a un vrai problème nous ne pouvons
pas faire le bonheur des sont leur
volonté sans leur adhésion je suis un
peu désarmé voilà je ne suis pas sûr que
ce qui est en cause le modèle du
développement ou le défi démographique
c'est l'absence de développement le coup
d'État sont chaque coup d'État est
unique mais il y a des facteurs internes
et des facteurs externes comme à
rappeler niagali et il y a eu une
période où à la fin des années 90 au
début des années 2000 il y a eu une
dynamique démocratique dans ce pays
particulièrement en Afrique de l'Ouest
avec des alternances particulières au
Mali au Niger des élections
démocratiques et puis on est on a
assisté à une période de reflux de refus
de la démocratie avec ces
3ème mandat qui qu'on a pu voir ici et
là en Guinée en Côte d'Ivoire et ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que voilà une
confiscation du pouvoir de la démocratie
fonctionnait plus facile et le fait que
la démocratie n'est pas un contenu
thermique a créé de la déception exact
auprès des est-ce que cette période
est-ce que cette période démocratique ça
a aussi créé parce que généralement
parler de de richesse de développement
est-ce que ça a aussi créé plus de
richesses dans dans les pays en question
et c'est c'est cela la conception envers
le modèle démocratique ou envers le
devoir membre de la démocratie a créé de
la déception auprès de population a fait
que bon les gens se sont mis à applaudir
le premier changement qui arrive dans le
cas le plus emblématique c'est celui du
Burkina Faso le président Roch Marc
Christian Kaboré a été élu en décembre
2020 il a été renversé un an plus tard
et 5 kilos élus au premier tour ont
voulu le coup d'État qui l'a renversé
donc il y a quand même quelque chose qui
qui n'a pas marché et je pense que le
devoir me de la démocratie ajouter un
peu à cette ambiguïté de la communauté
internationale qui peut s'accommoder du
coup d'État au Tchad tu condames le coup
d'État au Mali qui peut s'accommander du
coup de pas bon et d'ailleurs il n'y a
pas que la France lorsqu'on voit les
États-Unis leur attitude au Niger est
très ambigu pour les Américains au Niger
l'enjeu c'est l'arrivée de la Russie si
la Russie ne vient pas elle peut bon
continuer à parler avec la jeune elle
s'accommodera du pouvoir quel qu'il soit
grosso modo
américain aujourd'hui plutôt que de
défendre le retour alors
constitutionnelle elle regarde si la
Russie va venir ou pas et en parlant
avec l'adjointe nigérienne les
Américains ont dit nous on ne veut pas
que la Russie Vienne pour l'instant ils
n'ont pas rompu la coopération donc
cette ambiguïté et les facteur interne
ont créé cette situation le coup d'État
partout un peu partout sur le continent
et il faut trouver le moyen d'arrêter et
pour moi le meilleur le meilleur comment
dire
la meilleure prévention contre le coup
d'état c'est de retourner à la
démocratie et la vraie démocratie et
espérons que que cette option reviendra
on va dire en haut de la pile vous avez
parlé de France d'Afrique Géral anglais
c'est évidemment un des termes qui
allait venir dans un débat celui-ci on
va aller un peu plus loin sur ce thème
avec Steve Jourdain qui va nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
c'est la chronique de sens public à
entendre l'exécutif Steve la France
Afrique c'est fini c'est fini on va voir
cette entretien de Catherine Colonna
publié dans le monde ce lundi la
ministre des Affaires étrangères nous
dit et bien que la France inférieure est
morte et c'est pas nouveau selon elle
elle est morte depuis longtemps elle
ajoute que la ligne de la France est
d'être à l'écoute des Africains pas de
décider à leur place fin de citation
d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron lui-même
l'affirmé écoutez c'était au mois de
mars c'était au Gabon
notre histoire commune ici au Gabon ne
nous le cachons pas c'est aussi celle de
la France Afrique et cet âge de la
France Afrique et bien révolue j'ai
l'impression d'avoir déjà entendu ça
c'est pas qu'une impression votre
mémoire ne vous fait pas défaut on a
sorti quelques archives flashback je ne
dis pas qu'il faille nécessairement
faire table rase et tout effacé d'un
seul trade plume mais je dis que la
France souhaite engager des discussions
avec tous les États africains concernés
pour adapter les accords existants en
réalité du temps présent et en tenant le
plus grand compte de la propre volonté
des pays africains le temps de ce qu'on
appelait autrefois la France Afrique et
révolue il y a la France et à l'Afrique
et il y a le partenariat entre la France
et l'Afrique bon on a compris tout le
monde en terre depuis longtemps la
France Afrique mais c'est quoi faut
monter à la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale la France est progressivement
contrainte de quitter ses anciennes
colonies dans les deux décennies qui
suivent des mouvements d'indépendance
voient le jour l'empire colonial
français explose finalement dans les
années 60 une question très simple se
pose alors la France peut-elle se
contenter de quitter purement et
simplement ces territoires non estime le
général de Gaulle et son Monsieur
Afrique Jacques faucar qu'on va voir en
photo il faut perpétuer l'influence
française on va donc mettre en place des
régimes dans lequel on va tisser des
liens économiques des liens politiques
des liens monétaires des liens
militaires notamment en Afrique de
l'Ouest et en Afrique centrale pour
résumer Thomas la France Afrique c'est
une diplomatie d'influence qui s'appuie
sur des réseaux qui sont souvent opaques
par définition ce n'est donc pas une
politique officielle ce n'est pas une
politique revendiquée d'où la difficulté
à proclamer la fin pure et simple de la
France même si beaucoup de choses ont
changé depuis le général merci beaucoup
effectivement merci beaucoup Steve Jour
Dernier Bagayoko la France Afrique
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment complètement
disparu tous ces politiques qui nous
disent c'est fini alors il y a plusieurs
analyses de ce phénomène moi j'estime
que la France Afrique dans sa version
politique
a largement disparu il faut quand même
rappeler que dans les années 80 90 il y
a eu beaucoup de scandales en lien avec
ce système de connivence entre des
élites africaines et des élites
françaises y compris en ce qui
concernait le financement des partis
politiques français on est sorti de
cette aire en revanche il y a très
clairement encore des relations
privilégiées qui sont tissées avec un
certain nombre de régimes dont le moins
qu'on puisse dire et qu'il se caract
justement par la gestion
néo-patrimoniale et par la corruption le
népotisme qui
est propre à leur mode de gouvernance la
tournée du président Macron au mois de
mars ou l'été dernier a eu pour première
destination justement le Gabon d'Ali
Bongo alors au motif qu'il y avait la
conférence sur les forêts mais enfin
tout de même juste après un discours qui
annonçait que la démocratie faisait
partie de l'ADN de la politique
étrangère de la France choix et étonnant
tout comme les relations avec Paul Biya
avec Denis sassounguesso etc aujourd'hui
il est très difficile de donner du
crédit à une position qui a du mal à
faire le choix entre la le soutien à des
valeurs et la promotion d'intérêt et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il est assez
absolument mais souvent la réelle
politique il y a qu'à lire King singer
s'oppose à la politique de Brésil ski
qui valorise la promotion de principes
aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'on reproche en
effet à la France ou plus largement aux
partenaires
occidentaux c'est d'utiliser la
démocratie les droits de l'homme comme
un paravent leur intérêt et non pas
d'afficher très clairement leur Réal
politique si on parle du Gabon est-ce
que la France par intérêt économique
notamment pétrolier est-ce que la France
a soutenu la famille Bongo c'est aveuglé
la soutenu trop longtemps au Gabon non
je vous écoute mais bon je suis pas
complètement il y a des choix politiques
il se trouve que j'étais mise en défense
lorsque
l'ONU si et la troupe français la
l'armée française a Abidjan a réinstallé
le président élu Alassane Ouattara en
suggérant au président Gbagbo avec des
moyens assez énergiques de d'abandonner
la place nous l'avons fait sur une
demande des Nations Unies avec la
sentiment des pays de la Cedeo et de
l'ohua et nous l'avons fait avec des
moyens d'ailleurs extrêmement limité
comme nous comme ensuite le président
Hollande a décidé d'intervenir au Mali à
la demande du gouvernement malien parce
que s'il n'était pas intervenu il est
assez vraisemblable que des des raids
comment les qualifier islamiques
peut-être ça il y a un Touareg ce que
l'on veut en tous les cas qui
déstabilisaient l'État et qu'utilisait
la force comme on l'a vu
dans le nord du Mali la force et la
pression sur les populations civiles
avec un islamisme militant qui était
insupportable aux populations bien c'est
à leur demande il se trouve que nous ne
pouvons pas réussir un projet politique
avec des moyens justement militaire ça
j'en suis absolument convaincu je
connais trop l'histoire de mon pays pour
savoir que l'usage de la force militaire
n'a de sens que si elle est au service
d'un projet politique or il n'y avait
pas de projet politique au Mali et en
tous les cas il n'y a pas eu de volonté
de trouver un accord entre les
populations
je dirais du bassin de du fleuve et puis
et puis les populations mobiles et
nomades du désert alors s'ajoute à cela
évidemment la crainte de l'islamisme par
exemple vous avez raison de dire les
États-Unis sont Réal politique dans
cette affaire africaine il se fiche pas
mal et ils l'ont montré ce qu'ils
veulent simplement c'est que l'État
islamique ou ces filiales ou ces
associés prennent le pouvoir
qui prenait la suite de l'opération
Serval donc les soldats français sont
partis du Mali il y a un an qu'est-ce
qui se passe depuis est-ce que
ce qu'il
ont repris du terrain qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en dire il faut être très exact
lorsque les soldats français se sont
retirés du Mali le dernier soldat le 15
août 2022 qui a traversé pour aller au
Niger le Niger étant devenu aujourd'hui
les puissantes de la présence française
au Sahel la les emprises qu'ils ont
rétrocédé devaient normalement les
emprises militaires françaises devaient
normalement être occupés par les forces
armées maliennes et leur nouveau
partenaires les Russes et Wagner en
termes sur le terrain cette place n'a
pas été effectivement
occupée il y a eu un regain de
l'activité djihadiste particulièrement
dans la zone de trois frontières au
niveau de qui est commune au Niger au
Burkina et au Mali il n'y a pas eu de
valeur ajoutée et je pense que il ne
pouvait pas avoir de la valeur ajoutée
parce que une des horreurs qui a été
commise dans la réponse au défi
sécuritaire au Sahel c'est de penser que
c'est une question purement militaire et
sécuritaire on a on a c'est pour ça que
vous dites notre Afghanistan parce que
les résultats n'ont pas été à la hauteur
et ça ça pu alimenter le rejet de la
France on a pensé et y compris au niveau
en France et dans les pays de la région
que il suffisait d'augmenter le nombre
de soldats en janvier 2020 lorsque le
président Macron se réunit à Pau avec
ses homologues du sale et qu'ils ont
constaté que sur le terrain les rapports
de force n'était pas favorables aux
armées africaines la France a décidé
d'envoyer 600 soldats supplémentaires
les autres parce que on on est dans la
posture de penser que la solution est
purement militaire et sécuritaire alors
que le défi sécuritaire au Sahel a une
dimension économique le jeune qu'on peut
recruter pour 115 euros pour 110 euros
dans le groupe djihadiste la question de
la gouvernance la question de la
cohésion sociale tout cela si on ne
l'intègre pas pour construire un
paradigme qui soit qui amène une réponse
holistique on pense à côté de la
solution mais donc ça veut dire Géral
anglais qui a un constat d'échec de de
ces opérations fondamentalement l'échec
et politique il n'y a pas de projet
politique malien et jusqu'à présent je
ne le vois pas et il y a un repli du
gouvernement actuel sur des positions
qui sont régionales et comme on pourrait
dire ethnique je suis pas suffisamment
compétent pour trouver l'adjectif le
plus vrai mais en tout cas un repli et
une concession une sorte d'abandon les
positions qui étaient occupées au nord
ou dans la partie vraiment
aux limites du Sahara ne sont pas
détenus par le gouvernement qui se
replient et qui se sert de Wagner non
pas pour la paix au Mali mais pour sa
protection et sa sécurité spécifique
donc c'est un échec mais c'est aussi
l'échec des populations locales nous
pouvons pas faire le bonheur des gens
sans eux il faut aussi rappeler que
Wagner se paye sur les matières
premières de
très particulier de ce point
autant en Centrafrique il est évident
qu'il y a une exploitation éhontée des
ressources au Mali ça a été beaucoup
plus compliqué de passer un accord
notamment sur l'exploitation orifère
manifestement les partenaires russes
n'ont pas obtenu gain de cause moi je
pense qui est très important de dire
puisqu'en effet cette élément
sécuritaire militaire est absolument
central dans les dynamiques que l'on
voit aujourd'hui de rejet des
gouvernements africains et de leur
partenaire internationaux c'est qu'il y
a un échec collectif qui a vraiment
réussi à contrer la menace djihadiste on
enracinement son expansion y compris
vers les pays du Golfe de Guinée alors
bien sûr il y a eu des succès tactiques
obtenus par l'armée française mais
globalement on ne peut pas considérer
que
la France que le G5 Sahel les états
sahéliens avant tout bien entendu la
Russie parce qu'on ne peut pas dire non
plus que Wagner est obtenu les moindres
résultats en termes de capacité à
contenir la progression de cette menace
ce qui se passe au Mali aujourd'hui au
delà de la volonté de préserver le
régime c'est qu'on voit au contraire
reprendre la guerre contre les Touaregs
au nord c'est ça la préoccupation
aujourd'hui majeure à Bamako on le voit
si on suit alors ce n'est pas sur le
devant de l'actualité d'ailleurs je
pense que tout ce qui se passe notamment
au Niger permet de faire diversion mais
c'est ça qui se produit aujourd'hui mais
ça veut dire que je voudrais simplement
c'est le problème malien et c'est le
problème des Maliens je ne je
une immense respect pour notre armée
mais elle n'est pas capable de faire la
politique oui mais on les alliés dans ce
pays on l'a envoyé pour une raison très
simple c'est parce que des raids
islamiques souvent
de Bamako nous avons reçu la mission de
desserrer cet étreinte et dans limiter
le risque de renouveau au delà ce n'est
plus notre mission la mission des
Maliens c'est de s'occuper de leurs
affaires eux-mêmes c'est à l'époque
effectivement il y avait on parlait du
risque d'un d'un autre État islamique au
sel est-ce que ce risque existe encore
aujourd'hui non absolument pas la menace
djihadiste elle existe mais les risques
de voir s'installer en Khalifa islamique
avec des entités entières qui sont
contrôlés par l'État islamique ne me
paraît pas réel d'accord mais là menace
elle-même elle existe et elle continue
de se diffuser c'est là où c'est le plus
préoccupant le djihadistes ont un agenda
celui de porter la menace du sel vers le
pays du Golfe de Guinée et de ce point
de vue il y a aujourd'hui une
progression justement on n'a pas réussi
à contenir l'extension de la menace
territoriale l'extension territoriale je
veux bien dire puisque et elle est
descendue maintenant du sale vers des
pays comme le Bénin qui a été
régulièrement attaqué le Togo qui est
régulièrement attaqué et il y a cette
menace de
transposer la menace djihadiste du sale
vers le Golfe de Guinée et ça ça c'est
un élément important mais comme il a été
dit un des un des facteurs qui a pu
accélérer c'est aussi l'échec de la mise
en oeuvre de l'accord d'Alger en ce qui
concerne le le le en ce qui concerne le
Mali particulièrement
qu'est-ce qui avait été décidé oui dans
l'Accord d'Alger prévoyez un certain
nombre de choses notamment la
réintégration de tous les ex rebelles
touareg dans l'armée malienne au
gouvernement composé la possibilité
qu'il y ait des exécutifs régionaux avec
beaucoup de pouvoir tout ça a été remis
en cause et aujourd'hui comme à Digne
d'aller ce qui est le plus préoccupant
c'est que il y a une tendance à la
reprise de la confrontation entre les
accords les rebelles signataires et les
forces AR puisque la même alien a
réussi à avoir du matériel et il y a un
sentiment de monter en puissance qui
amène à cette tentation de reprendre
la rivalité avec les toiles qui
viendrait s'ajouter déjà à la rivalité
avec le groupe terroristes et qui
pourrait avoir des conséquences au-delà
du Mali sur la stabilité et la sécurité
de l'ensemble de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
alors là on peut parler de présence
militaire évidemment c'est lié on va se
concentrer maintenant un peu plus sur
les questions diplomatiques Mathieu je
me tourne vers vous parce que on va
parler de la ministre des Affaires
étrangères qui est sorti on vient de le
voir rapidement tout à l'heure grâce à
Steve cette interview dans le monde
sortie de son silence pour rappeler la
pollution de la France dans dans sa
politique africaine ça vous étonne oui
ça m'étonne un peu parce que jusqu'à
présent
occupé un portefeuille clé du
gouvernement Catherine Colonna et
melbrier surtout par sa discrétion alors
discrétion ça peut être une qualité
diplomatique mais on peut pas être juste
discret il faut aussi savoir parfois
dire les choses clairement et porter la
voix de la France c'est assez drôle
parce que quand elle a été nommée tous
les portraits qui sont parus au moment
de sa nomination ne manquez pas de
rappeler son CV parfait diplomate
chevronnée qui avait choisi le Quai
d'Orsay à la sortie de Léna qui a dédié
l'essentiel de sa carrière on rappelle
qu'elle a été porte-parole de la
présidente sous Jacques Chirac qu'elle
était ambassadrice çà Rome à Londres du
brexit bref tout le monde disait voilà
une parfaite ministre des Affaires
étrangères et en fait elle s'est révélée
depuis un an parce que enfin un peu plus
d'un an maintenant elle est là depuis
depuis juin 2022 assez transparente
assez peu connue des Français au point
que beaucoup de ses collègues au
gouvernement la donnait même partante au
moment du remaniement qui a eu lieu en
juillet dernier Argan que la voix de la
France manquait de coffre et que elle
avait même déçu en haut lieu à l'Élysée
et pourtant elle est restée et ben oui à
la faveur d'un remaniement qui s'est
avéré plus limité que prévu et parce que
au-delà de son style il est quand même
difficile de lui faire le reproche de ne
pas exister dans un domaine qui est déjà
traditionnellement réservé aux
présidents de la République et qu'il a
en plus voilà est considéré vraiment
comme une chose supprime le corps
diplomatique voilà par Emmanuel Macron
alors le tropisme international
d'Emmanuel Macron on est en effet plus à
démontrer on sait que le Président de la
République aime traiter en direct de
dirigeants à dirigeants face à face au
téléphone avec ses homologues étrangers
c'est encore plus vrai depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
c'est aussi vrai avec l'Afrique on l'a
vu recevoir où y aller et puis samedi
des Affaires étrangères et souvent
réduite un rôle de j'allais dire
télégraphie si j'étais méchant mais en
tout cas on on la voit pas à la manœuvre
comme on peut voir un blinken par
exemple dans l'administration Biden aux
États-Unis et pourtant les sentiers de
la diplomatie française sont énormes ils
sont énormes alors les on les connaît
tous rapidement il y a le dossier
ukrainien bien sûr qui finira bien par
retrouver une dimension diplomatique
malgré les essais jusqu'ici infructueux
auquel aurait pu le président de la
République et l'Afrique bien sûr dont on
vient de parler mais aussi les relations
avec les pays du Maghreb on sait que le
Maroc l'Algérie c'est quand même
particulièrement empoisonné en ce moment
la relation avec la France il y a le
Proche et le Moyen-Orient ou Paris
espère reprendre la main on le voit
faire des courbettes à certains pays du
golf et puis évidemment avec l'Arabie
Saoudite puis aussi la Chine et l'Inde
tiens ou le président de la République
allez très prochainement pendant l'été
je crois que c'était le 7 août de
mémoire il y a trois sénateurs LR au
gkuchi Bruno et Christian Combault qu'on
a adressé une lettre ouverte au
président de la République qui a été
signé par 94 parlementaires issus de
plusieurs bords politiques
la question qui se posait c'est
sommes-nous condamnés à l'effacement de
la France en Afrique Gérard longex
est-ce que vous répondez à ça on n'est
pas condamné et très facile bien au
contraire mais on est en compétition
avec le monde entier et c'est par là que
vous parlez de la Russie c'est pas la
préoccupation principale car la Russie
reste un pays sous équipé en finance en
technologie et en homme la Chine en
revanche elle a de l'argent de la
technique et des hommes les États-Unis
pour autant qu'il s'y intéressent à
l'Afrique ce qui reste à prouver
sont également des compétiteurs et nous
avons en Europe des pays plus moins
connus mais qui sont extrêmement
présents et utiles d'ailleurs aux
Africains je pense à l'Italie je pense à
l'Espagne le Maroc est très présent en
Afrique c'est un pays extrêmement
intéressant donc la France n'a aucun
monopole en Afrique et ce depuis 40 ans
il faudrait que les Français s'en
rendent compte un jour et il faudrait
qu'ils acceptent l'idée que les tâche
rose s'est terminée depuis 70 ans or
souvent quand les journalistes nous
parlent des relations entre la France et
l'Afrique ils ont l'impression que nous
sommes toujours présents c'est faux les
Libanais sont beaucoup plus présents en
Afrique noire que nous leçons et
français il y a à Dakar une école
catholique privée elle est elle est
portée à bout de bras par les Libanais
pas parler français donc il faut bien
accepter l'idée que nos 65 millions
d'habitants qui ont à développer un pays
qui a bien des difficultés non pas les
moyens humains
être présent en Afrique comme ils l'ont
été nous sommes dans une concurrence il
faut accepter cette concurrence merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat Sidi Kaba je rappelle le
titre de votre livre Mali Sahel notre
Afghanistan à nous livre publié aux
éditions impact voilà c'est la fin de ce
premier numéro de la troisième saison de
sens public je voudrais remercier encore
une fois toutes les équipes de Public
Sénat qui ont travaillé d'arrache-pied
pendant cet été pour nous offrir ce tout
nouveau décor j'espère qu'il vous plaît
on va continuer de le faire vivre ici à
Sens public et dans toutes les autres
émissions de la chaîne il est modulable
vous verrez vous vous centrez vous allez
sentir la différence voilà merci
beaucoup à demain belle soirée
[Musique]